hi I'm Nick Gillespie and we are at
Freedom Fest in Las Vegas and we are
talking with JC Bradbury of Kennesaw
State College you're an economist you'd
write a lot about sports and kind of big
pork projects massive one happening in
Atlanta tell us about that
well just recently the city of Atlanta
after the state passed decided it was
going to give significant subsidies for
the new Atlanta Falcons hitting the
stadiums gonna be one to one point two
billion dollars and the city that's what
they say now by the time it's finished
it'll be a little bit more right exactly
and that's one of the things we often
find about these stadiums they always
underestimate the cost and overstate the
the benefits and it always takes longer
than they say the way this works and we
see this at every level of sports in
every part of the country you know
somebody will say look this is a major
you know boon to the local economy it's
gonna create jobs you know money's gonna
be falling out of the sky that is never
true talk about why these stadiums are
not actual public works projects well
you know it's very interesting that ever
this is a great case of the scene in the
unseen it's that people see money going
into stadiums people spending their
dollars at the stadium going to the
games buying food and what people don't
see is that really this is just a
transfer from locals spinning their
money instead of spending on going to a
movies or going out to eat they're going
to a sports game and so it looks like
it's generating a lot of money and it's
something that politicians love it
because everyone seems to like sports
well and then it's also that taxpayers
sometimes not even in the area that the
stadium is in are on the hook for this
so you can actually spread the cost of
building the stadium to other people
right especially when you have state
governments that are funding the for it
for a city why does this keep happening
everywhere we turn there's a new
publicly financed stadium or a
relocation deal or something going on
why do we keep getting suckered by this
part of the reason is that it's just
it's this rational ignorance here people
like sports and when a politician is
trying to do this what are politicians
like most of the time you're looking at
upper upper income educated males huge
sports fans so if I'm looking into this
unlike a library or some our parks on
the republic project I'm pretty much
guaranteed season tickets for life if I
help an owner get a
there's definitely some individual
benefits to legislators city councilmen
and so I think that's part of the reason
why it's so popular and you can you can
make a name for yourself and because of
the concentrated benefits to owners and
the dispersed cost you're talking about
something like five to ten dollars a
year coming out of a taxpayers pocket
it's not worth forming opposition for us
I think that's why these programs are
constantly getting through you know talk
a little bit in our final minute here
you know what do you do with the
argument and I hear this a lot
especially in second third fourth tier
cities where you know in order to be a
world-class City we need to pay a lot of
money out of our pocket that we're
already broke but we need to bust the
budget in order to bring a minor league
baseball team or a major league baseball
team or update the stadium how do you
you know
is there any way to combat that well I
think just my main argument is that you
need to force politicians to be honest
please don't take my money and tell me
you're doing something good for me you
know
you know at this point out hey this is
this is bad and I think that you do see
politician actually come out and say you
know what this is a good focal point for
our community as much as I don't like
funding public stadiums there's no doubt
that the New Orleans Saints were a
positive impact on the katrina community
but don't tell us that it's gonna help
make New Orleans an economically viable
city again just say that hey this is
good for the community and just try and
keep politicians honest because they
don't they don't make money and I think
it's a bad example for other public work
projects that they might be good is it I
mean is it the case that you know you
you never become a world-class city by
you know bringing a you know a double-a
ball team to town or something like that
but but is it is it a sign that you've
become a world-class City when you're
either big enough or stupid enough to
waste money I'm bringing a major league
franchise to to your enviros well I can
say this I grew up in Charlotte North
Carolina and we were we always were the
envy of know we're a big city I remember
when the Hornets came to town and we've
built the Charlotte Coliseum and before
they even paid off they blew it up it
was a total boondoggle but definitely
they were playing into the insecurities
of charlatans or saying oh we're a big
city and so that's what politicians are
constantly playing to but something like
a minor league baseball team I mean
really you're not you're not a big-time
city when you have minor league baseball
and I say this is a huge sport fan who
loves going to these games but let's
just be honest about what we're actually
building well JC Bradbury I want to
thank you very much for talking to
reason TV at Freedom Fest we were
talking about
courts and economics and why taxpayers
seem to be on the hook so many times for
big sports stadiums and whatnot for
reason TV I'm Nicholas pee